سفارات الانذار تدوي في مستوطنات غلاف غزه
بعد ثمان ساعات من الهدوء وبعد استهداف
قيادي في سرايا القدس
الكرملين يقر بصعوبه الحرب في اوكرانيا
وكيف تعلن اجبار القوات الروسيه على
التراجع في مخموت
واشنطن تحشد اربعه وعشرين الف عنصر على
حدودها تحسبا لتدفق مهاجرين
ينتظرون عند حدود الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
في تفاصيل يتواصل لتصعيد في غزه فقد قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه تم اطلاقه ست قذائف
هارون من القطاع على اسرائيل وان القبه
الحديديه اعترضت اثنتين منها اعتذارك
بعدما فاد الاعلام الاسرائيلي بدوي سفارات
الانذار في مناطق اسرائيليه محاذيه لغزه
بعد ثمان ساعات من الهدوء بما اكد المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي تنفيذ
158 هجوما بينما اطلق الفلسطينيون 515
قذيفه صاروخيه من قطاع غزه تم اعتراض اكثر
من 153 منها وحول حصيله الضحايا في غزه
قالت وزاره الصحه ان عدد قتل الغارات
الاسرائيليه ارتفع الى 25 فلسطينيا
والاصابات بلغت سته وسبعين
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان استهدف القيادي في
سرايا القدس علي غالي مسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه جنوب غزه وثلاثه فلسطينيين
بينهم قياديون في سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري للجهات
[ضحك]
الخامس
اعلن البيت الابيض الامن القومي الامريكيه
تحدث مع مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
الى ضروره استمرار الجهود في المنطقه
للتواصل لوقف اطلاق النار مشددا على ضروره
تهدئه التوتر ومنع اراقه المزيد من الدماء
كما جدد دعم الاداره الامريكيه الحازم
لامن اسرائيل وحقها في الدفاع عن شعبها من
الهجمات الصاروخيه العشوائيه
تنضم الينا من حدوث قطاع غزه مراسله
العربيه لا ناكل خاص اهلا بك لانا ما اخر
التطورات على الارض
هنا الهدوء يسود على حدود القطاع مع يعني
الحدود مع قطاع غزه ولكن نسمع ايضا هناك
طائرات الاستطلاع التي تحلق بشكل مكثف علي
ما يبدو فوق قطاع غزه هذه ايضا الطائرات
تسمى بطائرات الزنانه حسب
الفلسطينيين لانها يعني ذات صوت عالي
ومرتفع ما يؤدي الى ازعاج كبير ايضا
للمواطنين وهذا الهدوء يعني يسود حاليا
ولكن قبل فقط نصف ساعه كان هناك ايضا
اطلاق لرشاقات جديده من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي خرجت من قطاع غزه نحو
المستوطنات غلاف غزه هناك كان هناك ايضا
قبل قليل سفارات الانذار كانت تدوي في
مناطق مختلفه من المستوطنات التي نتواجد
بالقرب منها هنا ولكن يعني الهدوء يسود
الان فعليا ويعود الى الهدوء هنا في قطاع
غزه طيب هناك ايضا التطورات سياسيه ترافقت
مع تطورات الميدانيه ما اخر التطورات فيما
يتعلق بجهود التهدئه بعد تصعيد الاخير
صحيح صحيح كان هناك جهود يعني امريكيه
وايضا جهود من قبل بعض الدول العربيه مثل
مصر وقطر ولكن يعني على ما يبدو ان هذه
فعليا المحاوله للتهدئه لم تصل الى يعني
لم تصل الى حل نهائي على ما يبدو وذلك
لاننا ايضا راينا رشقات صاروخيه تم
اطلاقها من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه من
قطاع غزه نحو المستوطنات صباح اليوم بعد
هدوء دام ثمان ساعات فعليا لان اخر
القصفات من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
الطائرات الاسرائيليه كانت فعليا بمنتصف
الليل كان هناك ايضا هدوء من الساعه
الثانيه عشر منتصف الليل حتى الساعه
الثامنه وعشرين دقيقه منذ صباح اليوم حسب
التوقيت الفلسطيني هنا في
الحدود مع قطاع غزه ولكن يعني على ما يبدو
ان يعني
حاليا عاد ولكن يعني ربما ايضا سوف يكون
هناك مفاجات واطلاق لبعض الصواريخ
الاضافيه في المستقبل سوف ننتظر لنرى ما
ممكن ان يحصل ولكن فعليا القوات
الاسرائيليه قالت ان وقف اطلاق النار هو
سوف يختبر بالاقوال ليس بالاقوال عفوا
وانما بالافعال لذلك سوف ننتظر رد فعل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لا هناك الغاصي شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا هذه هي التطورات في محيط قطاع غزه
ولكن ماذا عن التطورات داخل القطاع ينضموا
الينا صحفي احمد حرب احمد كيف هي الاوضاع
لديكم هل
تكشفت نتائج الغارات الاسرائيليه الاخيره
بالمزيد من التفاصيل فيما يتعلق بالوضع في
القطاع
يعني ابدا معك زميل محمد من اخر الغارات
الاسرائيليه والاستهدافات الاسرائيليه كان
هناك استهداف قبل قليل في بيت حانون
الشماليه قطاع غزه لارض زراعيه فارغه من
الطائرات الاسرائيليه تم استهداف ارض
زراعيه فارغه وايضا جاء بالتزامن مع
استهداف ايضا ارض زراعيه فارغه في بيت
لاهلي ايضا شمالي القطاع ولكن احمد لماذا
تقوم اسرائيل باستهداف تلك الاراضي التي
اشرت اليها بما انها اراضي فارغه
اسرائيل او الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان هذه
منصات تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي منصات
صواريخ
تطرقها باتجاه المستوطنات والبلدات
الاسرائيليه المحاذيه للقطاع وبالتالي يتم
استهدافها من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن يعني يمكن القول عنها
ارض زراعيه فارغه ولكن حسب الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يقول بانها منصات تابعه
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي تطلق من خلالها
الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المحاذيه للقطاع ايضا في الساعه الماضيه
كان هناك اطلاق لسته قذائف من الهاون
باتجاه مستوطنه كوسوفييم المحاذيه لقطاع
غزه ولكن ما نشهده وما نلحظه زميل محمد
بان يعني هناك انحصار في كثافه اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه
وايضا في الغارات الاسرائيليه يعني باتجاه
قطع غزه او على مناطق متفرقه من القطاع
ولكن الحدث الذي حصل ليلا هو اغتيال مسؤول
الوحده الصاروخيه علي غالي في شقته في خان
يونس جنوب قطاع غزه ومعه شقيقه واحد
الجيران تم اغتيالهما بشكل مباشر من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه هذا الامر
سوف يزيد من تعقيد الامور على الارض لان
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي في الساعات القادمه
ربما تقوم باطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه المحاديه للقطاع وربما تصل
مدايات هذه الصواريخ الى تل ابيب وابعد من
تل ابيب على كل حال هذا هذه التطورات
الميدانيه والتحركات الميدانيه يقابلها
ايضا يعني تحركات دبلوماسيه وسياسيه
واتصالات مكثفه مع الطرف الفلسطيني بما
يتعلق بالفصائل الفلسطينيه وايضا
اسرائيل من قبل اطراف اقليميه كمصر والامم
المتحده وايضا هناك دخل على الخط المستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي كلها بها الاتصالات
الوقت جهود التهدئه مستمره من غزه صحفي
احمد حرب شكرا جزيلا لك
قال المتحدث باسم الكرم لاند متري ان
العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا صعبه للغايه
ونقلت وكاله تاس عن قوله ان تحقيق بعض
الاهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
باوكرانيا كان صعبا لكنه اكد ان روسيا
نجحت في الحاق اضرار جسيمه بالجيش
الاوكراني واضاف بسكوفان بلاده ستستمر في
العمل لتحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا
من جهته قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه انه هجوما مضاد لقوته نجح في
اجبار القوات الروسيه في بخموت على
التراجع قال القائد العسكري الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه تراجعت لمسافه تصل الى
كيلو مترين في بعض مناطق بخموت هذا واكدت
مصادر ان التراجع تم من احياء في المناطق
الغربيه للمدينه
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
يؤكد احراز تقدم في محادثات جده واشنطن
تؤكد ان الخيار العسكري ليس الحل
اهلا بكم من جديد في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال رئيس مجلس القياده اليمني
رشاد العليمي ان الشعب اليمني يتطلع
للحياه وليس الموت قائلا ان الدعم
السعوديه طالوا جميع المجالات
اليمنيه يحتاج للسلام ويحتاج الى الصحه
ويحتاج الى الخدمات ويحتاج الى الطرقات
ويحتاج الى الحياه لا يحتاج الشعب اليمني
يتطلع للحياه ولا يتطلع الى الموت ان
الدلاله الرئيسيه لهذا التزامن مع السلام
هي رساله رساله ليست فقط الميليشيات
الحوثيه وانما ايضا لدعمها النظام
الايراني الدعم لها ان الشعب لان ان من
يدعمنا اليوم في تحالف العربي بقياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يدعمون
بالصحه ويدعمون بالطرقات ويدعمون بكل
المجالات
في سواء في المشاريع او في اللقاثه من
خلال مركز الملك سلمان وبالتالي انا اعتقد
هذه الرساله مهمه جدا في هذه اللحظه يجب
ان
يلتقطها الشعب اليمني اولا سواء في مناطق
المحرره او في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
الحوثيين وهي رساله قويه ايضا ميليشيات
الحوثيه واللداعمها
اننا نريد الحياه ونريد المزيد من
المشاريع والتنميه والسلام
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه اليمني وفي
مقابله الخاصه مع العربيه اكد ان افتتاح
العدد الكبيره وافتتاح العدد الكبير من
المشاريع السعوديه في اليمن ياتي لدعم
الاقتصاد والتخفيف عن المواطن اليمني ياتي
افتتاح والتدشين حزمه من المشاريع للبرامج
السعودي في عدن في ظل الجهود سياسيه حديثه
تبدلها الرياض
لوقف الحرب واحلال السلام ما دلالات هذا
التوقيت واهميه هذه المشاريع في هذه
المرحله اولا اهلا وسهلا بالعربيه نحن
دائما نتطلع
لان نكون مع العربيه دائما
وشكرا لكل جهودكم التي تدعمون فيها المجلس
القيادي الرئاسي والحكومه والشعب اليمني
فيما يتعلق بموضوع المشاريع اليوم لا شك
ان هناك دلالات كثيره
لتنشئين وافتتاح هذه المشاريع اولا تعرفون
ان البرنامج السعودي بدا
ولا شك ان هذا البرنامج عندنا بدا كان
هناك الكثير من التحديات والصعوبات وكثير
من المشاريع تحتاج الى مسح
وتحتاج الى تخطيط وتحتاج الى دراسات
واعتقد ان هناك
متطلبات
لانجاز الكثير من هذه المشاريع سواء من
حيث التخطيط او من حيث التنفيذ وهذا
يستغرق وقت طويل اليوم النتيجه كانت
والثمره لهذه السنوات الاربع هو افتتاح
وتدشين هذا العدد الكبير من المشاريع على
مستوى عدن كعاصمه مؤقته وعاصمه الاقتصاديه
ايضا وعلى مستوى المحافظات اليمنيه
المحرره
وبالتالي هذا التزامن انا اعتقد انه وضع
طبيعي
من خلال الوقت الذي اخذوا البرنامج لكي
يقوم بانجاز مثل هذه المشاريع
تستمر المحادثات بين وفدي الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع في جده بواسطه سعوديه
امريكيه واكد الناطق باسم العمليه
السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف ان تفاؤلا حاضرا
بات يلوح في الافق على الرغم من
الاشتباكات المستمره في العاصمه الخرطوم
المباحثات في جده كما قال يوسف بات تقترب
من التوصل الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في
اي لحظه كما اشار الى احتمال اتفاق الجيش
والدعم السريع على انهاء الازمه والاقتتال
الدائر في السودان وشدد الناطق باسم
العمليه السياسيه على ان حل الازمه التي
تعيشها البلاد هو الخيار السلمي
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الخارجات الامريكيه
انها ستحمل قاده السودان مسؤوليه استمرار
العنف مشدده على انه لا حل عسكريا للازمه
في السودان هذا واعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه
عن امتنانها للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات
بين الطرفي الصراع في السودان
نعمل مع السعوديه للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
نار دائم في السودان واكدنا للشركاء
والحلفاء ان لا حل عسكريا للازمه نحن
ممتنون للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات جده
بين طرفي الصراع ونؤكد اننا سنحمل قاده
السودان مسؤوليه استمرار العنف
حشدت الولايات المتحده الاربعاء 24 الف
عنصر امن استعدادا للرفع وشيك لاجراء صحي
كان معمولا به منذ بدايه جائحه كورونا
وصعد حينئذ في ترحيل مهاجرين عابرين برا
نحو اراضيهم وقال وزير الامن الداخليه
الامريكيه لخاندرو مايوركاس ان الايام
المقبله قد تكون صعبه بعد رصد عدد كبير من
المهاجرين الوافدين الى الحدود الامريكيه
قرروا ترامب المثير للجدل ينتهي الخميس
قانون تايتل 42 سمح للسلطات الامريكيه
برفض المهاجرين المكسيكيين وذلك بحجه نقل
وباء كورونا للولايات المتحده عشيه انتهاء
القانون تكدس الالاف من المهاجرين على
الجانب المكسيكي من الحدود ما دفع
الولايات المتحده لنشر اربعه وعشرين الف
عنصر امن على حدودها ومن المتوقع ان يستمر
الامر كذلك لاسابيع
اعلنت كوريا الجنوبيه تخفيض مستوى
الاجراءات المتخذه لمكافحه فيروس كورونا
بدءا من يونيو المقبل وقالت الحكومه ان
الفرق المتخصصه لن تطالب المصابين بالحجر
الصحي لمده سبعه ايام على ان تواصل سلطات
الصحيه توصيه بخمسه ايام من العزل الذاتي
للمصابين لكنه لن يكون اجباريا كما سيتم
ايضا اسقاط متطلبات ارتداء الاقنعه في
جميع المرافق الطبيه والصيدليه
اعلنت اليابان ان زلزالا قوته 5.4 درجات
بمقياس رختر ضرب مقاطعه تشيبا وتسبب في
اهتزاز المباني في طوكيو صنف زلزال على
انه قوي من الدرجه الخامسه على مقياس شده
الياباني المؤلف من سبع درجات في مدينه
كيسارازو
في الختام تذكيرا بالعالم
سفاره الانذار تدوي في مستوطنات الغلاف
بعد ثمان ساعات من الهدوء وبعد استهداف
قيادي في سرايا القدس
يقر بصعوبه الحرب في اوكرانيا وكيف تعلن
اجبار القوات الروسيه على التراجع في
بخموت
واشنطن تحشد اربعه وعشرين الف عنصر امض
على حدودها تحسبا لتدفق مهاجرين ينتظرون
عند حدود الولايات المتحده
هيئه النشره شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات